ouverture aujourd'hui au tribunal
correctionnel de paris du procès de la
ferme il a treize personnes sont jugées
pour cyber harcèlement et menaces de
mort l'adolescente a déclenché une vague
de haine sur les réseaux sociaux en
janvier 2020 pour avoir critiqué l'islam
deux accusés ont formulé des demandes de
renvoi qui sont examinées aujourd'hui le
point avec ben hassen chébili sur place
ouverture aujourd'hui au tribunal
judiciaire de paris du procès de la
terreur numérique 13 personnes âgées de
18 à 30 ans doivent comparaître
aujourd'hui dans la ferme il a mis là
c'est cette adolescente iséroise qui a
été menacé de mort et harcelés en ligne
après avoir publié des vidéos polémique
sur l'islam elle a été accueillie par
beaucoup de journalistes quelques
minutes avant le début du procès
beaucoup d'inconnues attirés par cette
histoire qui souhaitaient être là pour
assister au procès je vous propose
d'écouter maître malka son avocat à
l'entrée de l'audience moi je m'en
remets pas tous les jours et je ne me
remets pas non plus du fait que l'école
notre système éducatif lui ai dit
qu'elle ne pouvait pas la protéger et
que ce soit elle qui ait été écartée
alors que ceux qui lui promettaient de
se faire tabasser si elle remettait les
pieds au lycée n'ont eu aucune sanction
je ne me remets pas non plus du fait
qu'on ne lui ai pas trouvé un autre
établissement scolaire je ne me remets
pas que l'armée est considéré qu'elles
ne pouvaient pas la protéger et qui va
aider mieux qu'elle reste chez elle je
ne me remets pas qu'elles vivent
recluses depuis 18 mois je ne me remets
pas que ce soit la seule jeune fille de
ce pays pour la première fois de notre
histoire qui doivent être protégés 24
heures sur 24 par des policiers imaginez
sa vie elle ne peut plus aller en
terrasse tranquillement elle peut plus
se balader dans la rue elle peut plus
avoir de stage elle paye à elles toutes
les portes lui sont fermées
c'est insupportable c'est très individus
âgés de 18 à 30 ans inconnu des services
de police est très actif sur les réseaux
sociaux ont déclaré pendant leur garde à
vue aux enquêteurs avoir agi à chaud
sous le choc et l'émotion
deux des avocats ont déclaré vouloir
formuler des demandes de renvoi des
demandes de renvoi qui ont été rejetées
par le tribunal et qui a considéré que
ces demandes étaient sans objet les
traits individus comparaissent
aujourd'hui au tribunal et risque
jusqu'à deux ans de prison et 30000
euros d'amendé pour harcèlement et trois
ans
de prison et 40000 euros et d'amande
pour menaces de mort